we've been observing the freefall of
Donald Trump since he decided to shut
down the government as this temper
tantrum because he didn't get money for
his border wall we've already seen more
than one poll confirming that Trump's
approval is down his disapproval is up
Nancy Pelosi's approval keeps going up
but we now have a much more extensive
and detailed Quinnipiac poll about these
and other issues and it's even more
drastic than we thought the impact over
the last five six weeks of this shutdown
now I'm going to give you numbers and
what you have to remember is that the
bar is really low for congressional
approval
okay congressional approval is
historically low period in general
Congress has a terrible approval rating
some of the highlights from this
Quinnipiac poll number one Democrats in
Congress have a 38 percent approval
rating right now this doesn't sound that
high but it's actually the highest since
July of 2009 it's been almost ten years
since Democrats in Congress have had an
approval rating so high number two
voters who trust Pelosi more than Trump
now make up forty nine percent forty
nine percent of the American electorate
and 56 percent now blame Trump and the
Republican Party should really be and/or
the Republican Party for the government
shutdown these are really significant
numbers and to understand you might look
at them and say everything is kind of
like between 40 and 60 like is this
really that significant it's significant
on the Democratic side again ten years
since there's been 38 percent approval
for Democrats in the house half of all
Americans trust the Speaker of the House
more than president Trump that's a huge
number when you account for how
polarized the United States of America
currently is now that third number is
not actually that great when when I hear
that 56% of Americans blame Trump and/or
the Republican Party for the shutdown
they're right that is a majority it's
the right answer
but it's also way lower than it should
be because if 56% of Americans believe
that either Trump or Republicans are to
blame for the shutdown that leaves 44
percent that means 44 percent of the
American public either blames Democrats
for the shutdown that remember Trump
promised ahead of time and then did or
they don't know who's to blame both of
which are problems and this is why you
just can't rely on people switching to
the right vote in order to win an
election if after everything that has
happened here
Trump famously and furiously ranting in
the Oval Office to Nancy Pelosi and
Chuck Schumer about how he would be
proud to shut it down
you still have some Democrats like Tulsi
Gabbard playing the both sides or to
blame game when it comes to the shutdown
after all of that that we saw we end up
with only 56 percent of the country
confidently saying it was Trump's fault
or Republicans fault that the government
shutdown that means we're in trouble for
2020 right this is what I've been
talking about Pat any reasonable person
should understand that this is the Trump
shutdown
he promised to shut it down he said he
would own it if he did and then he shut
it down that's it like that there's
nothing else to it here and yet 44
percent of the country is either not
reasonable or not informed which is how
you get president's re-elected with
approvals in the 40s or mathematically
it can even happen with approvals in the
high 20s we can't count on people
realizing what's going on we need to get
new people out there and voting I think
at the beginning of the government
shutdown the vast majority of people
knew that it was the Trump shutdown but
after a little while just a couple of
weeks I think neutrality bias starts to
set in and people find it Noble and
sanctimonious to say well it's it's
important that both sides come together
and find a solution to this we just have
to blame all of Washington for this and
you know some people just don't follow
politics closely enough and if they're a
federal worker not getting their
paycheck they don't care exactly who to
blame there
it's one side of the other they just
want to blame both sides because they
need to get paid and they're going to
just try to do whatever they can to make
sure that they get that paycheck I think
that's what happens once these things
drag on and we could be facing another
one in another couple weeks there could
be another one February 15th for sure
and this is why I mean the call to arms
here is okay we are getting an inkling
that resistance to Trump's antics is is
good it's seen favorably Democrats in
the House and Nancy Pelosi specifically
have had significant increases to their
approval the more that they have
resisted Trump when it comes to the
State of the Union the shutdown border
wall funding everything okay that's a
glimmer
that's a glimmer of hope most people
blame Trump for the shutdown okay that's
good it's a little concerning that it's
only 56% but the most important takeaway
from this poll in terms of like okay
what do we do now in terms of 2020 the
most important takeaway is that assuming
people understanding the world will lead
to Trump losing in 2020 is wrong okay
any version of look at X that Trump did
obviously people are going to vote him
out in 2020 you've lost like you've
conceded the game that is a losing
approach and that is why I am so over
and over and over I am making clear that
approval ratings don't matter
favorability ratings don't matter who is
elected bility games at this point
aren't what's important voter turnout
voter turnout and thus also fighting
voter suppression which is already
ramping up for the 2020 election even
though it's barely February of 2019 so
my focus is going to be that this is
going to be an election if it's going to
be won in 2020 that is going to be won
on solidarity from the left saying the
number one goal is Trump out okay and
the understanding that it doesn't matter
what state you're in it doesn't matter
how much you think
your vote will make a difference it
doesn't matter anything else other than
you need to vote and you need to work to
get other people to vote because it is
going to be determined by turnout period
I'm on Twitter at D Pakman the show is
on twitter at david pakman show we have
a great program for you today I will be
answering audience questions we will be
hearing from the audience during live
calls as well and on the bonus show by
the way we will be hearing about Pats
upcoming vacation which I know is very
very exciting to Pat and we'll see what
the audience thinks of it as well one of
the day's sponsors is privacy comm slash
Pakman which is a free service that I
myself use really useful in many
different ways takes just a few seconds
to link your debit card to privacy comm
then you can create virtual credit cards
that are linked directly to your bank
account and you use those virtual credit
card numbers to buy things online which
protects your actual debit card so that
it's not spread all over the internet
and one of the best things about it is
how their mobile app and browser
extensions for Chrome and Firefox make
it really easy to use let's say for
example that I'm signing up for a david
pakman show membership in the credit
card number field I already see the
privacy comm icon I just click it choose
which of my virtual credit cards I want
to use and the credit card number
expiration date and security code are
automatically entered I can put in any
zip code I want and I'm done and if you
try to use my credit card number that
you just saw on the screen it doesn't
matter because I've already deleted that
virtual card and that's the beauty of
privacy calm there are a ton of
advantages to using a free service like
this for example you can sign up for as
many free trials as you want then just
delete the virtual credit card you used
and never worry about getting charged
for it it protects you from getting
hacked it protects you when companies
are hacked which happens all the time
it is all completely free all you have
to do is click the link under this video
to get started
and for a limited time they're giving
everyone in our audience $5 towards your
first purchase when you sign up using
that link